[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Самчики
Волинь]
Оце вам приклад настінного розпису, оце є самчиківський розпис,
тому що розпис колись писали на стінах.
Потім, з часом, вже перенесли його на папір, на плакетки.
Я – директор художньої самчиківської школи,
[Віктор Раковський,
майстер самчиківського розпису]
член спілки національної,
і займаюся розписами по Україні,
і майстер-класи проводжу.
І в Самчиках, зараз магазин
буду розписувати, вже почну.
Це єдина школа в області, де діти
вивчають суто вузьке направлення,
вивчають народний розпис.
Але не тільки
народний розпис,
але і писанкарство, і витинанки,
і розпис на склі.
Немає об'ємності.
У петриківському розписі там
зовсім інша техніка виконання.
Береться два кольори на пензлик
і одним мазочком
робиться плавний перехід,
градація кольору або тону робиться:
від світлого до темного,
від жовтого до червоного,
а в нас робиться кольоровими площинами.
Подивіться: пляма, пляма, пляма, кольорові плями, бачте, кольорові плями.
Розпис плоскісний.
Разом з тим, розпис – сюжетний, тому що в кожній картині є сюжет, є тема, є зміст.
Що ми використовуємо в написанні?
Квіти. Навіть і запах можна показати.
Далі, пишемо птахів –
це символ вірності, любові, злагоди.
Пишемо тварин.
Таких тварин, які найчастіше зустрічаються в нас:
це кінь, це може бути і собака,
може бути котик.
От, це ми маємо розписати дві зупинки:
в'їзна з Києва, в'їзна звідти з Хмельницького.
Вибрали, кажу, такі старі будиночки,
такі, які підлягають розпису.
Ці розписи будуть між вікнами,
оце буде на боковій стіні,
У цьому будинку, там є бокова стіна велика.
І оцей будиночок також буде
розписаний.
Ми використовуємо сюжети з пісень,
сюжети з колядок, щедрівок,
з української народної творчості.
У мене батько працював оформлювальним художником.
Я заходив часто до нього в майстерню,
мені і сподобалось це,
я почав десь із сьомого класу
спочатку вирізати,
дуже було тоді модним
пласке різьблення на фанері.
От, збиралися там в
майстерні,
допомагали одне одному.
І так потроху, потроху.
Ви не думайте, що це робилось за один день.
Це воно роками: шукали
свій стиль, свій характер.
Вирішили, що варто у нас школу відкрити
щоб зберегти оці традиції розпису.
Тому що розпис самобутній,
він за характером відрізняється
від багатьох розписів, від всіх розписів.
Я працював на різних роботах,
остання була далекобійником.
[Сергій Касьянов
Майстер самчиківського розпису]
Так вийшло, що трошки мене здоров'я
підкосило після рейсу.
Віктор приходить до мене і каже:
«Іди до мене в школу».
Я трошки вирізав по дереву
Каже: «Будеш дітям різьбу викладати».
Почав малювати, пробувати,
бо бути в цій когорті
і не малювати – неможливо.
Треба було використовувати цей шанс.
Подобається це, більше не
хочу нічого міняти в своєму житті.
Зараз багато є продовжувачів нашої
роботи, слава Богу.
Нам допомагають дівчата з UAmaze.
Так в арт-тури сюди приїжджають дівчата, показуємо, вчимо їх.
Зараз вже нас не четверо.
По цій вулиці в нас будуть там ще шість будиночків,
загальноосвітня школа,
де будуть присутні наші розписи.
Тобто ми хочемо розписати
у характерному, в одному стилі,
разом із тим, щоб залучити сюди туристів, і організувати такі своєрідні арт-тури.
Коли людина приїжджає, повинен
бути той самий «ефект ах»,
що їдемо, нема нічого,
а тут одразу щось цікаве таке,
багатоколірне, таке колоритне.
Першим у нас піде ось цей магазин, оце арт-кафе.
Там збираються творчі люди: музиканти, поети
і так само художники збираються.
Олівцем зробив ескіз,
і це ж сьогодні хочу з другої години дня поїхати взяти фарби, і почати працювати.
Зверху буде невеличкий розпис.
Кафе називається «Самчиківка».
От тарілочка така вітальна:
здоров’я, щастя, любов, злагода,
тобто запрошення до гостини.
Проходьте, будь ласка, сюди.
Наталю, готуйся.
От розписано, бачте, кафе в такому нашому стилі.
Ну така тематична композиція для діток, подивіться,
де основна композиція
наша – дерево,
і журавель прилетів ввечері
на старе дерево.
А по чому видно, що це старе дерево?
А от сова сидить в дуплі,
але разом з тим дерево
бореться за життя.
Дивіться, воно старе,
але на ньому ще квіти ростуть.
Дуже було забуте в нас писанкарство.
Якраз я прийшов у 1983 році після служби.
Я служив на флоті, і в цьому приміщенні,
на другому поверсі, ми ховалися.
У цьому приміщенні ми ховалися,
щоб писати писанки.
Було засилля, як кажуть, партійної,
комсомольської організації.
Це було фактично заборонено.
Для того, щоб писати,
ми вечорами ховалися тут.
Десь у 1984-1985 роках ми почали
відновлювати традиції писанкарства,
традиції розпису, килимарства.
Розпис зараз відроджується, і люди бажають чогось нового, цікавого, свого.
Не зарубіжного, не запатентованого
десь, звідкись, а свого.
Розпис треба зберегти.
Оскільки на нас покладена ця місія,
то мусимо її виконувати.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Режисерка монтажу
Анна Воробйова]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]